let's see who else is on the phone why
don't we go to the three two one area
code caller from three two one who's
this where you calling from hello
that is you babe oh yeah it's doghouse
important I just had a quick question
about how it's been for the coffee a
quarter we were in general okay you have
a follow-up I said yeah yeah yeah I
wanna um was running with what your
overall analysis over was and because
I've watched a couple of your videos
that you posted about her and I'm not
saying that sure just like most people
who attack her for no reason because you
do have valid criticisms about her okay
like the way she called himself a
Democratic Socialist was she's actually
a social democrat like that
well the criticism okay but um I I just
don't really see you doing as much
positive coverage so I just wonder
what's your overall opinion of what her
contribution has been to politics and
she like announcer primary okay so a but
I mean so listen what what positive
things can we say Alexandria Castillo
Cortez has done number one she has shown
that even though the power of incumbency
is it is it windy where you are Dante
yeah I'm gonna do my best to get get
this out although the power of
incumbency is significant she shows that
it is not absolute she took down an
incumbent establishment Democrat in her
district
that's fantastic number two she has
become a prominent voice for many of the
great ideas of the progressive movement
right now including single-payer health
care including a living wage
including just basic anti cronyism
measures if government shut government
shuts down elected officials should not
get their salaries right and she's not
the first to have said any of this stuff
so I think that that that's all
fantastic she's bringing young energy
she increases the diversity of the
legislative body all great stuff
the the counter to that would be I think
she's quite uninformed about many issues
I think she lacks knowledge about many
issues and will she learn about these
things as she is in Congress I certainly
hope so and I and I assume that she will
oh all right Daunte thank you appreciate
the call I am thrilled to tell you that
today's episode is sponsored in part by
Blink asam / Pakman blink astiz a really
unique service for your phone tablet and
web browser and it is incredibly useful
for people like me who love books and
learning but are busy blinka steaks the
best and most popular non-fiction books
and condenses them into 15-minute
audiobooks I'm sure that if you're like
me you have a very long list of books
that you've been meaning to read you
only have so many hours in the day and
that's why blink astiz so amazing they
take the most important information the
themes the insights from each book and
they distill it into a 15 minute audio
book that you can listen to in one
sitting I've listened to a ton of books
on blankets our audience can get a 7 day
free trial by going to blink is calm /
Pakman if you're watching on YouTube
I've put a link in the description I
have listened to blinka spokes about
economics about political science about
history about science so many
interesting things and after the free
trial if you like it you can continue
enjoying thousands of condensed
audiobooks for about 5 bucks a month go
to blink is calm / Pakman that's B Li NK
is t.com /pa ke ma n